I kind of like this clip not because Fox News
anchor Chris Wallace is some huge critic of Fox
News while being on Fox News. But because it's
a thinly veiled shot at some of the nonsense
that's been regurgitated by Fox News since the
election, including remember this story of right
wingers going after Dr. Jill Biden because
she's being called doctor without being a
medical doctor. So let's look at this clip
from Sunday's interview where Chris Wallace
interviewed incoming White House press secretary
Jen Psaki. Let's take a look at the clip.
Finally, there has been some criticism recently
from conservatives, including some conservatives
on Fox News about the fact that first lady to be
Jill Biden goes by the title. Doctor, I wonder,
what is the Biden's reaction to that, especially
given the fact that so many people over the years,
I think of Dr. Henry Kissinger, the Reverend Dr.
Martin Luther King, have gone by the title doctor,
even though they're not medical doctors and
nobody seems to have made a fuss about that.
That's exactly right, Chris. It's a bit perplexing
to me and I'm sure to millions of Americans that
with thousands of people dying every day of covid
millions out of work, that anyone would wake up
in the morning and decide that the focus they
need to have, the way they contribute to society
that day is to question whether or not Dr. Jill
Biden, someone who's still teaching, who has a
Ph.D. in education, should be called a doctor or
not. Of course she should. As anyone who works
through that challenging process of getting
a Ph.D., it's it's a really silly, sexist
and absurd conversation that's happening a bit in
society. And I appreciate you asking me about it.
Jen, thank you. Thanks for your time.
The criticism from conservatives on Fox News,
Chris Wallace says now, as I said
on the stream that I did yesterday,
we have a very backward situation right now where
people without any college degrees or people with
bachelor's degrees in areas that have nothing to
do with education are evaluating the merits of
Jill Biden's doctoral thesis, her dissertation
about education, random right wing journalists
with no experience in policy or in the academic
field of education, or saying criticism of Dr.
Jill Biden is fair because her dissertation was
crap. There's a bigger picture here that exists
on the right and it's been growing over the last
some odd years. A flash point was when former
Republican Senator Rick Santorum said college
is liberal indoctrination and let me see if I
can sort of lay it out. One of the laughable
things that happened yesterday at this event
by Turning Point USA, which we covered, is that an
incoming Republican congresswoman defiantly said,
I will go and debate any professor at any college.
Hold on. What do you mean debate? Any professor
like you would debate in astronomy professor about
the planets. You'll debate a chemical engineering
professor about chemical engineering. But what do
you mean you'll debate any professor? And what I'm
guessing she was implying is she would debate any
professor about politics. But it's this arrogance
and perspective that's become a via it's like a
mind virus. And it's the same sort of delusion
that's taking place with Dr. Jill Biden. This is
similar to when people evaluate the merits of Dr.
Jill Biden's dissertation without any knowledge
that would allow them to do that. People who
have never been to college or people with college
degrees in an unrelated topic, random bloggers,
everybody gets to evaluate the merits of Dr.
Jill Biden's doctoral dissertation. This is very
common on the right. The idea that really you
just learn opinion at college and mostly it's
liberal opinion, liberal professors giving liberal
opinions and then the students take the liberal
opinions and they repeat them. Science is liberal.
They believe or infer rather than an empirical
process. And there's a Dunning Kruger aspect to
it where they so misunderstand what college is
and what empiricism is and what science is that
they don't know that there's a difference between
having an opinion about what the tax rate should
be and empiricism and the scientific method that
they end up lacking the capacity to understand
what is happening in college and to even critique
it in a credible way. That's how they end up
thinking. It's merely liberal nonsense. I can show
up and debate any professor and I can determine
whether Dr. Jill Biden's doctoral dissertation
is meritorious or not. But in any case, good for
Chris Wallace, sort of kind of softly alluding
during his interview with White House press
secretary, incoming White House press secretary
Jen Psaki that some of the Dr. Jill Biden nonsense
has actually been happening on Fox News itself.